foreign
[Music]
with more and more critical applications
being run on cloud providing highly
available Services has become
increasingly important this is because
even a short downtime of these
applications or degradation of user
experience can cause significant losses
for the organizations both in monetary
terms and user trust thus having the
ability to monitor the health of vital
Cloud resources is crucial for the
organization's success
in this video I'll show how to configure
and use cloud monitoring's uptime check
to monitor our VM instance
to start with let's understand what
uptime checks are the uptime check is a
simple yet powerful observability tool
to track resource availability on an
ongoing basis and detect any issues
uptime checks send requests to public
and private endpoints at regular
intervals and record whether the HTTP or
TCP request succeeds or fails uptime
checks with an alerting policy can
detect availability and latency issues
with the resource notify in a timely
manner and thereby reduce the impact
caused by an outage
an uptime check consists of two
components number one uptime check
configuration
created by you to schedule periodic
requests from Google Cloud regions to
the targeted resource for example you
can configure an uptime check to send
https queries to your application and
then create an alerting policy to
monitor the uptime check results so that
you are notified if your application
fails to respond second the request
execution system provided by Google
Cloud that manages the following
execution of configured checks
validation of results and writing
results to uptime check metrics Cloud
monitoring offers two types of uptime
checks number one public uptime checks
this type of uptime checks issues
request from multiple locations
throughout the world to publicly
available URLs or Google Cloud resources
public uptime checks can determine the
availability of monitored resources such
as VM instance app engine application
kubernetes service Cloud run revision
Amazon elastic load balancer and many
more second private uptime checks these
checks Issue request to internal IP
addresses all private endpoints of
different resources for example with
private uptime checks you can send
requests over the private Network to
resources like a virtual machine or a L4
internal load balancer today I will show
you how to create an uptime check to
test a public endpoint
before creating an uptime check ensure
you have following prerequisites number
one required permissions to create or
manage uptime checks using Google Cloud
console your IM role must include
monitoring Editor to configure and
manage uptime checks using API your IM
rule must include monitoring uptime
checks configuration editor monitoring
alert policy editor and monitoring
notification Channel editor second
verify the resource you want to check
has a public endpoint or behind a
configurable firewall third verify and
configure notification channels you want
to use to receive alerts alright let's
dive into a demo and learn how to create
an uptime check to test public endpoint
by using Google Cloud console
first go to uptime checks under
monitoring click create uptime check
select the protocol we can choose HTTP
https or TCP
next select the resource type that needs
to be monitored here you can choose
different type of resources
in our example we will select instance
you can select a single instance or a
group of instances defined as a
monitoring group then select the
instance to monitor this is a dynamic
feed and changes with respect to
resource type next select the frequency
for uptime checks executions we will
keep it as default that is one minute
optionally if you want to configure
options or Regions icmp Banks port
number or other fields click on more
target options
click continue to configure response
validation options the response timeout
lets you specify how long to wait for a
request to complete default is set to 10
seconds which we will be using in our
demo next if you want to configure of
time check to perform content matching
ensure that content matching toggle is
enabled here you can select response
content match type this field determines
how the response content is compared to
the return data in the next field enter
the response content this must be a
string no longer than 1024 bytes for
this demo we will keep content matching
disabled check mark log check failure
checkbox if you want uptime failures
save to login next select acceptable
HTTP Response Code for HTTP of time
checks here it can be classified by code
classes specific codes or any response
codes
click on continue to configure alert and
notification
while the uptime checks collects the
data about eligibility of VM instance
you must create analytic policy to be
notified remember alerting and uptime
checks are integrated so most fields in
the alerting policy are already
pre-configured for you all you need to
do is enter the name of alert and set
the notification Channel Next select how
long the uptime checks must fail before
notifications are sent default value is
one minute and we will keep it the same
click continue to review summary of
configured options on the review page
verify all the fields are set as desired
from the summary on the right pane next
enter a name for the uptime check
optionally on the next field user
defined levels for uptime check can be
added to verify your uptime check
configurations click on test Google
recommends testing your uptime check
configuration before creating finally
click create awesome the uptime check
has been created to learn more about
uptime checks check out this
documentations
foreign
[Music]